plusieurs années d'abord je
roule en deux fers à tonnerre
d'applaudissements à tous les
jeunes qui organisa cinq ans
plus tôt
djaâboub cinq ans
il n'existerait pas falardeau
d'après de standaard
il ya trois ans
dans mon département de la
seine-saint-denis
un homme est venu main sur le
coeur
faire une promesse à la
jeunesse qu'il allait tout
donner à la jeunesse
mais françois hollande c'est
lui qui a pris la jeunesse c'est
lui qui a créé la jeunesse en
avant les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
combet que tous les jeunes de
france et d'ailleurs c'est une
double peine parce que c'était
bon à la fin du mois +1 pour
l'année d'après il a voulu ce
prix met les bourses au mérite
et je vous demande de faire un
tonnerre
le raisonnement de faire un
tonnerre d'applaudissements
parce que si les jeunes
républicains avec lui
s'étaient pas mobilisés
aujourd'hui les bleus se mérite
n'existerait plus vous pouvez
mais d'après le dr
la propriétaire par jeanne
et laissé à l'abandon au
lycée
mais les ventes sont en hausse
il n'a rien fait
face
un ps qui craint que la misère
mais ils feignent qui sortent de
ce nul je vous réponds genou
jeanne républicain nous tentons
d'y être
mais que voulez-vous des jeunes
françaises et des jeunes
français alors mobilisez-vous
engagez-vous parce que ça vaut
le coup et avec marine grenier
à noter au bureau national nous
serons en permanence à vos
côtés à votre service dans
les trois bureaux dans les
territoires ruraux dans les
quartiers populaires dans les
zones urbaines vous pouvez
compter sur nous allez-y à fond
mobilisez-vous surtout sur les
élections régionales
sur tous les sites allemands
face à la ténacité la traîne
avec sa meilleure forme
en paca notamment en asie
avec christian estrosi je pense
que tu pensais pourtant
marie-monique est très engagé
avec son côté christian
estrosi et bien sûr on est en
france abete valérie pécresse
une candidate
lorsque la trêve
au service de tous
ebay qui d'ailleurs m'a demandé
de vous faire un petit vent
parce qu'elles ne peuvent pas
être présents parce qu'il est
toujours et encore sur le
terrain
alors maintenant je n'ai plus
qu'à vous dire mobilisez-vous
car nous devons aussi être
ensemble autour de nicolas
sarkozy elle me convient bien
pour gagner ces élections
régional de décembre prochain
j'aimerais aussi avoir une
petite pensée pour mon ami
stéphane ticket
stéphane
mais après un contrôleur
elle s'est fait sauter avec son
grand-père maternel et avec la
même année nous continuerons
de cdc entreprises
et enfin
mais chère amie
j'ai effectué une question à
vous poser il est opposé à des
jeunes républicains
joseph à santander
je propose en recomposant pannes
jusqu'aux portes de l'élysée
question est posée à tous
déjà depuis quelques années
plus tard
alors à la barre
pour les régionales et pour la
jeunesse de france je vous
remercie